Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, hopefully you’ve
all had a chance to watch some of my comic
con videos.
I asked everyone on twitter which new footage
they wanted me to do a breakdown for and Age
of Ultron won as expected.
There were a ton of new trailers, so at the
end of this video I’ll explain which other
ones I’m going to be doing.
And I’ll announce who won my Marvel giveaway.
Hello to any new people, if you just found
me because of all the comic con stuff I do
weekly Marvel videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
This week Guardians of The Galaxy is in theaters,
it’s going to be awesome, so I’ll be doing
a bunch of separate videos for that.
Plus they already confirmed a sequel for 2017.
But let’s talk about that Avengers 2 trailer.
In case you didn’t see it, it ended up being
pretty close to the scene I described in an
old video from a couple weeks ago.
It was the party scene in the Avengers Tower.
The clip at comic con had a bunch of new stuff
in it though.
I know a lot of you have asked about the actual
footage and no I can’t just post the trailer.
It’s super illegal.
Those people that leaked the Deadpool test
footage and the Batman vs Superman clip.
Fox, Marvel and Warner Brothers are going
to throw them into a deep dark pit.
Marvel was really nice and released a bunch
of images, so when I’m talking about the
footage I’ll use those.
First we saw the Party Scene.
It’s a fully operational Avengers Tower.
It’s sick how awesome it looks.
If you remember, Tony Stark and Pepper Potts
were looking at blueprints of it at the end
of the first Avengers movie.
So this is what the floorplan is.
All of the avengers including Thor are living
on earth full time.
Guardians of the Galaxy happens about 6 months
earlier in the timeline, but they haven’t
interacted with the Avengers yet.
I repeat yet.
What’s been happening since Winter Soldier
is that the Avengers have been cleaning up
the Hydra Labs, like the one Baron Von Strucker
was in with Quicksilver, Scarlet Witch and
Loki’s staff.
Because HYDRA was so embedded in the organizations
of the world, the day to day grind of cleaning
up all the remnants has gotten too exhausting
and to maximize efficiency and vacation time.
Tony Stark creates Ultron.
He’s like an 8 foot tall robot built from
modified elements of Iron Man suits.
But he has a new AI system capable of learning.
Skynet Terminator style.
Ultron’s mission parameters as defined by
Tony Stark are to eradicate evil and make
the world a better place.
Cue scary music.
Because of the way machines think, the cold
efficiency and because of Tony Stark’s loose
language in eradicating evil.
Ultron determines that humans are the problem
and for the good of the planet.
They need to be eliminated.
Thus Ultron begins his war against the Avengers,
armed with his own army of Ultron replicants.
The Avengers Trailer goes from this party
scene with all of them laughing taking turns
trying to pick up Thor’s hammer but only
Captain America is able to make it budge,
just a little.
During that scene, everyone in the audience
went crazy.
In the comics Captain America has used Thor’s
hammer, but he’s never done it on screen.
So you guys will go nuts when you actually
see it in the movie.
Ultron busts in during the party and says
“There is one path to peace, Your extinction”
and opens fire on them.
Then it cuts to a montage of WTF action scenes.
Explosions all over the world, Bruce Banner
in the woods, tanks fighting in the snow.
Tony Stark has this line where he says, “It’s
the end, the end of the path I started us
on.”
and Black Widow says “Nothing lasts forever”.
Then in a different scene Tony is fighting
the Hulk in his Hulkbuster armor.
This is the concept art, but here’s a look
at a prop replica of the arm.
Freaking awesome right?
Then it cuts to a scene of Ultron saying,
“Look, no string on me.”
- you have to picture James Spader saying
it in his creepy Blacklist voice.
It’s basically that, processed to sound
more like a machine voice, like JARVIS.
Then it ends with a scene of Tony in a wasteland
of battle debris with all the other Avengers
lying on the ground like they just got the
shit beaten out of them.
Even Captain America’s shield is cracked.
Here’s a shot of the prop in real life.
It’s the scene that happens after this promo
image.
The big posters they revealed over the course
of the weekend.
They went up against Ultron and his army and
got their asses handed to them.
Andy Serkis appeared briefly in the background
of a battle scene.
It was super quick, but it was live action,
meaning he wasn’t a mo-cap creature and
he was most definitely evil.
So when you theorycraft who he’s playing,
think of human villains in the Marvel universe.
I don’t think it’s MODOK or anything.
That’s more of an old Patton Oswalt joke.
That’s pretty much it.
But you’ve seen what Ultron looks like in
his final form.
This poster isn’t what he first looks like
when tony stark builds him.
Before he rebels he looks more like an Iron
Man suit.
One of the first things Joss Whedon explained
about Ultron was that we would see him evolve
mentally throughout the film and physically
as he upgrades himself.
If you guys watched the panel footage I uploaded,
when Josh Brolin came out with the Infinity
Gauntlet.
It made me think.
What if Thanos steps in to help for a price.
Like bargaining the tesseract for his assistance.
Of course Vision will be the one to finally
take Ultron on directly.
He’s explained as the good son of Tony Stark,
Ultron being the Bad Son.
So think of Avengers 2 as a story about two
brothers, Ultron and Vision.
Like Cain and Abel in the biblical sense.
Except the ending is different.
Everyone was a little disappointed that Marvel
didn’t roll out a Tom Hiddleston level opening
at their panel.
They have 6 new mystery films and didn’t
announce what any of them were.
I think there are a couple big reasons why,
mostly all practical.
The biggest is that they have a ton of unsigned
deals with actors, writers and directors for
all those films.
And until all those people sign ink on paper.
Those films could change.
Think about Ant Man.
A bunch of people just dropped out of the
movie, the script isn’t finished and they
start shooting in August.
That’s only a couple weeks away.
That’s how far behind they are.
Joaquin Phoenix was the newest rumor for Doctor
Strange.
As weird as that choice sounds it doesn’t
matter.
No one they’ve offered the part to has signed
a contract.
And it’s the same story for all those other
movies.
The other big reason why they didn’t tease
phase 3 stuff is Guardians of the Galaxy.
It’s being released this week.
And if they talked about too many other films,
they’d steal a lot of thunder from it.
So they wanted to promote it more than they
wanted to promote a movie coming out in 4
years.
It sucks that they didn’t confirm anything,
but they did drop Guardians 2.
That’s being released July 28th 2017.
James Gunn had already said he’d direct
the sequel if the first one did well enough.
And based on projections and early ticket
sales, it totally will.
Looking back on the weekend I still think
the Marvel panel was the best, with the Batman
vs Superman Warner Bros panel being a close
second.
Michael Douglas old-mansplaining Ant Man was
a bit of a drag, but he’s Michael Douglas,
what do you expect?
I’ll be doing a bunch of separate Guardians
videos for that movie this week including
a review and a Guardians 2 video with all
the stories I think they should do.
Be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff.
Really the big tease is them bringing Nova
into the movie.
That’s really the next big step for that
franchise.
And deepening the Thanos lore in preparation
for Avengers 3.
I did a bunch of giveaways this past week.
I tried to do one for each of the shows and
movies I do on my channel.
Like one for Marvel, one for Arrow, one for
the Flash, you get the idea.
I’ll announce the winners of each of those
when I make trailer videos for those things.
The winner of my Marvel giveaway is Amy Hailes.
Congrats, you win a Marvel Funko pop figure
of your choice.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
I’ve got at least 8 other giveaways still
running right now, so if you have won something
but haven’t got a message from me, just
let me know on twitter.
There’s a link for that at the bottom of
the description.
My next video is going to be a breakdown of
the Arrow Season 3 Ra’s Al Ghul trailer.
You can click here to get it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
the video.
And you can click here for the whole Marvel
Comic Con panel.
It was pretty awesome.
Thanks for watching see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!